she was with her rocker looking
boyfriend he looked like he was a part
of the Red Hot Chili Peppers
she knew what she was doing so stop
looking at
[Music]
welcome back everybody to another
awesome episode of the careful boys and
today we have Mr silent Mike
[Applause]
Michael silencio who's a huge fan of
Crunch bars worst chocolate bar ever
made
this is a fun fact he's Latino
oh Barry nice this is an off the Record
prompt that was submitted by one of our
patrons hola on the live stream that we
had earlier today so this is a fun topic
so what we're going to talk about is
what some of our childhood dreams were
versus maybe what some of our adult
dreams are now I wanted to motorboat my
second grade teacher
[Applause]
you still hot Mr
Mr Larson no because she had like kind
of low-cut shirts she was a young
teacher she had nice boobs and she loved
to give hugs she she loved to give hugs
and I think my my biggest dream was to
put my face in her boobs yeah do you
still have the same dream as an adult
now I don't know what she looks like
you're probably hot well I saw her at a
road trip that was really cool a road
trip yeah wow like recently no no when I
was uh when I was a kid me we were going
to San Francisco and we were going on a
road trip and then
um I was we were like at a gas station
and when I was walking out I saw her her
low-cut shirt again she was with her
rocker looking boyfriend he looked like
he was a part of the Red Hot Chili
Peppers oh she knew what she was doing
so stop looking at me why
imagine that
Hey Joe we're not at school anymore
[Laughter]
and she's all sorry Joey he's a little
intense
it's a [__] outrageous situation that
was good oh my God I caught me off guard
that's so like ridiculous for that that
is so 90s though yeah dudes would be
acting like that
no so motorboat James that's that's a
good one did you ever get to fulfill
those dreams not with your teacher but
like a teacher yeah yeah or just
I just remember feeling her boobs when
we hugged and all the boys loved punks
from her
like oh my God this is really nice
and you make eye contact with another
kid and he's like
and then I wanted to be a pirate that
was a big dream of mine what kind of
pirate
what led that what led that because
that's before like [__] parts of the
Caribbean and [__] yeah before it was
cool yeah it was Pirates of the
Caribbean at Disneyland that was kind of
cool oh no that right that was based on
Captain no was it Captain Cook no the um
the book that where the kid stows away
on the on the ship and then it and then
the captain is the cook but he takes
over the uh the the pirate boat it's a
book here Treasure Island Treasure
Island that's the book yeah yeah Hook
was good though I love Peter Pan yeah
that was my yeah I think that's what
started it is Peter Pan look all that
stuff the Pirates were the adults though
so it's kind of like yeah still tough
but that like yeah but just the pirate
world all that stuff there was a lot of
pirate stuff as a kid yeah and then I
watched uh Miami Vice and I didn't
really know what drug dealing was but I
thought it was cool when they were
chasing each other in boats and then
shooting each other oh that's awesome
yeah so I was like when I grow up I want
to move to that area I knew like the
Caribbean in Florida was kind kind of
like one whole area and I wanted to get
speed boats and have guns and like be a
pirate modern day now that was my dream
till the fourth grade I think fourth or
fifth yeah and I got in big [__]
trouble because we were supposed to talk
about your future careers and stuff yeah
no so he's like I want to be on a boat
with some guns and chasing people so we
our our project I I think this was like
third grade or something like that
we make tissue
so like in school you would you know we
would draw like our tissue box with our
future like what kind of whatever and
then I made like a car with missiles in
a [__] boat with a machine gun and
all this stuff right and then when we
got up it was my turn to talk about it
and then I got in trouble for that and I
was like you're gonna [__] tell me
what my dreams is and I can't even have
my own dreams [__] you yeah I just kind
of I didn't even know that is kind of
sad though they tell you the homework's
to do your dream and like no you can't
do your dream they should have given you
credit for being that creative at least
it's pretty cool yeah or should have
maybe educated you yeah that's crime you
say that would be really great to be a
director of a movie like that yeah yeah
they should just correct you a little
bit yeah just yeah redirection redirect
I even got a journal right here with me
with a picture of me in fourth grade and
I did that I have a missile car I
spelled [__] so wrong
Pirates don't need to speed yeah but
that that was what I really wanted to do
that's why I thought that I was really
gonna go into the military and all that
stuff you could have been Navy SEAL
probably I have [__] guns on boats
yeah I literally do that every day yeah
damn but I didn't go that way
were you able to get any bit of that for
your future you think that's probably
why probably it went to crime and gangs
and stuff and joined the street gang
yeah now you have like a paddle board
and you got guns so you can tell I'm a
Hawaii pirate you're about 20 there yeah
it's close it's probably closer than you
know if you would have just been a
regular you know adult oh yeah I guess
so you're kind of an irregular adult
that's true regular what's your what's
your dreams now
dreams now yeah [__] man that's
interesting because I I forgot to dream
like that like well
um I have an idea and I just worked
toward it
it's a different kind of mentality I
don't think I have a um
um so when you're a kid when you're a
kid I realize like you're so limited I
remember I can't wait to be an adult so
I'm like you know when kids they just
love playing and being in their
imaginary world right but I thought it
was so cool to be an adult because you
had freedom you could drive you could
get a job you could do whatever the [__]
you want and then like you don't have to
go to school you can make money eat ice
cream for dinner you could yeah like
it's like all those choices I thought
were so cool because then
like people who own a business or they
have a job or they could do something
right and then I'm stuck at school
studying about real life versus living
real life yeah so I was like I can't
wait till I get older and I can like
have a girlfriend that's like hot and
[__] and kiss her you know because
you're not trying to kiss girls your age
or like I know pedophile yeah if you
never thought like that like I was like
I don't want girls in my class they're
too young I want a [__] college girl
Joe was already an adult in like a third
grade body so you want to make them a
pedophile
I was jail-based no I remember fat I did
like okay I had a girlfriend right like
I had crushes in elementary school but
then when you looked at a girl in
college or like when you look at a
Playboy or women in swimsuits right that
was like the the top [__] like girls
your age were like
they're gonna be that one day but that's
not who you want you want the Pamela
Anderson at least for me yeah that's
true you're not cutting out like the
toddler section of JCPenney and then
putting it all over your room
I'm not getting teen magazine girls and
putting them on my [__] wall and
import tuna girls like sungh Healy and
stuff
my life sounds hot it's hot you're
getting cut out to like 20 something
year olds even though you're like 13 or
10. I didn't even know they had jean
shorts that small yeah I thought it was
underwear yeah yeah Jean underwear
Jean lingerie hey you know though like
there's something that's like on the the
serious tip though that Joe said right
now like when you become an adult like
so many adults stop dreaming and I think
that's a kind of a thing you know what
I'm saying like as kids like you dream
and obviously some dreams are totally
deflated and things like I don't know
motorboating your teacher maybe like
maybe that's still an accomplishable
dream it is accomplishable yeah um but
the point is you know what I mean like
um I just lower Bohannon now kid okay
there it is and kids kids who dream
right people who would dream and have
those things like Ambitions and
aspirations
they end up doing something but a lot of
adults when you like stop dreaming uh it
I don't know it takes away something
magical for what like your life's
purpose is regardless of the things that
you actually have to do it's not like
your career is your purpose but like
maybe you're working to like earn stuff
to like fulfill other purposes but like
when adults stop dreaming that I feel
like that's when the world stops yeah I
said that's when you start tucking in
your shirt yeah and they're [__] life
I'm never gonna check on my shirt again
my dreams are boring now
so like so so like I dream about
planting like an avocado tree that's not
bored it's cool going fishing with my
that is freedom that's not boring that's
gay but it's normal you know what I mean
like
your dreams are crazy
you're like or like even if like even in
my early 20s right my dreams like oh you
know what I can't wait till I [__] go
to Egypt and then when no one's looking
I'm gonna climb the pyramids
so you're
still I'm gonna go be a [__]
world-class art Thief right you have
these crazy dreams and then like at this
point my dream is like oh I can't wait
to like [__] go spear fishing it's
achievable you could do that next week
it's not we might need to hear a couple
of the other guys in the room's dreams
because yours are interesting I love I
love them I support you I I'm gonna
piggyback because I think later in my
life I'm like dude when I get older I
think my second chapter of my dream that
I'm gonna start achieving is like I'm
gonna get into woodworking bro I'm gonna
build a [__] table I might build a
boat that's honestly tired like in my
head I'm like I can't wait to start
doing that type of [__] I'm just not
there yet that's like second half once
he finishes [__] playing his avocado
tree you could chop that [__] down and
use the wood yeah maybe you can make a
bowl and make guacamole with yeah right
like like chopped on my avocado tree I
just got it but that's how he makes a
bowl and has the guac
my dreams [__] work with this [__]
good old lamp dude what other dreams you
got you know childhood when I was a kid
I remember I was in the second grade I
wanted to be an FBI agent
but I just remember thinking like that
was a fantastic did you watch a movie or
something and you thought probably I
used to watch all kinds of [__] but I
always liked the you know when they
[__] flash their backs and they're
wearing jeans that's living that's what
I would think no but I remember as a kid
I would always be very like oh I want to
do that and then
I don't know what happened to that dream
I think my dream died bro you grew up
dude or you became one and you just
can't tell us yeah I'm a [__] narc
dude I was like I'm not gonna be no
snitch dude are you good at
investigating did you like Carmen San
Diego I felt like in my mind I I I was
fascinated by that kind of stuff like
investigating you know but it's not
something that I think I just died out
really quick I was like I'm I think at
one point in my life actually I was like
I'm no smart enough to be an FBI you
know who I think is the first person to
ruin their dreams so your parents yeah I
think so what do they say that's true
you ain't never gonna be that and then
your dad goes back to making [__]
horseshoe noises on the on his own
he's like he's taking the Coconuts like
a Monty Python
you'll never be that get a real job on
FBI agent you shut up
take three Jumanji
shut up
I don't think they it was them honestly
yeah like I feel like they were pretty
discouraging no no maybe not there I
think it was me I think it was me you
put yourself down yeah for sure I think
that's the Asian way a lot of ways I
think responsibility is like a dream
killer
um yeah like what when you got to make
money yeah taxi yeah right like they're
actually physically limited to do [__]
like you said like now you can go spear
fishing but someone who has no money
spear fishing's still way out here money
maybe spearfishing is their way yeah it
does go away it does the pendulum swing
it does I remember what it was growing
up I would associate like being
um like an authority figure like that
with like not being cool or like not
being like a lack of Personality or like
yeah yeah yeah Square so I was like oh I
don't want to be like that kind of guy
like I don't want to be a [__] you
want to be a hall monitor yeah like she
like closet dreamed it kind of yeah I
just was like yeah whatever I was like
like I just didn't think my personality
would match that like I'm not that kind
of guy you know so I think you told me
Square dude [__] you dude I'm [__]
round bruh no I'm not I'm not that
square [__] around I'm pretty Square
I'm pretty Square I'm pretty straight
it's okay he's an FBI do you wear
women's shoes you're hella cool dude
these are men's shoes I think hey you
match your socks to your shoes that's
really good on you oh thanks man this
wasn't uh this wasn't on purpose I don't
know into his pants lucky that means a
lot to me I can't be rocking like Adidas
sausage I can't do that yeah I can't do
that you don't so maybe it's a quinky
dink dude I have a stigma from from
getting made fun of in high school for
doing that so yeah you can't do it now
really I just grew up playing basketball
you never did that yeah can't do it yeah
you get dunked being too matchy-matchy
you know there is one childhood dream
it's not my main one but I realize that
it's connected to an adult dream that I
probably still have in some way shape or
form that I hope I'm man enough to
accomplish one day
um it's probably why I love things like
Robinson Crusoe or like the TV show
alone random stuff like that because I
remember as a kid I always wanted like a
sick ass tree house that I could just
escape to Oh and it was just you know
you see that [__] in like The Simpsons
right and it's just something that you
wanted especially when you wanted to not
be at home with your parents or
something like that that was a big one
yeah you just wanted your own space I
just wanted my own space but maybe also
being thrown into the Boy Scouts and
stuff like that like there was always
this thought that I I could like survive
yeah you know what I mean so when you
hear about those like Robinson cruso's
or Tarzan stories like I was always
infatuated with that because it was like
a person that was put into the wild and
could like [__] take it and then I
watched shows like alone now right where
it's like that's the competition where
they gotta [__] be out there and
survive you think you can do it
I wish I could obviously I'm not that
good but like I there's a part of me
that even in my adult now still like
there's something about that's cool to
me yeah I didn't know you were like a
[__] Wilderness dude that's the thing
I in my adult years I have even done
that because you make me think of
glamping
but he was a boy scout he's an eagle
scout but that's oh I know that but then
the Anthony that I know today he doesn't
go into the neighborhood today I haven't
in a long time and that's true I I
understand that but definitely when I
was growing up as a scout when we were
in competitions with like the white
troops and stuff like that at Camp
reviews I would oh we would always be
the Vietnamese scholarship because I was
in a predominantly Vietnamese group
um we would always be like [__]
getting punished and very militant troop
and doing push-ups and stuff when we
like left our shoes out or something and
then all the [__] fat white kids had
like car batteries and their tents
playing TV Mario Kart and [__] like that
you know what I mean or like just
cooking like these Anthony dug a hole
like Viet Cong style in a certain way
booby trapped everything and maybe that
gave me a confidence like I could
participate so you did some of it okay I
did do some I'm confident I could
definitely laugh and do some stuff yeah
I don't know bro do you watch those he
was in Boy Scouts bro I went to Waldorf
what does that mean so I don't know if
Astoria no that's a hotel it's a school
because I'll tell you that I Was A Boy
Scouts too I wasn't an eagle scout but
my troop camped once a month at the
minimum yeah from when I was 10 to when
I was like 16. yeah that's so cool so I
mean if he's an eagle State okay okay
okay okay okay
so most schools for their eighth grade
trip or some go to a museum or Six Flags
or something we did seven days on the
Eel River up north in Oregon with two
leaders my teacher in 20 12 year olds
that's it no cell phone no nature you
didn't see it or only no nature only
only buildings no you didn't you didn't
see a single human besides our class and
two people what was that you guys are
all tents or capitals neither we're on
the nothing so what you sleep in the
sleeping bag you you had a sleeping bag
and we had tarps that you would lay out
it rained you're getting rained on
that's pretty cool yeah crazy [__] you
have bear spray you're really cool I
just don't want you to [__] on my
coolness no you're [__] cool and I
wanted to relate
these [__] were dead and you
and I are women alone we're winning
alone
because you try to [__] on them no what
I'm trying to say is that whack-ass trip
you had he did that every summer for at
least six years
different eight days straight maybe it
was nine or ten I don't know dude it was
a long time I'm gonna ask you is that a
GB yours cause I be doing that [__] and
I feel like we should all go into the
forest as the careful boys and survive
that'll be a vlog I actually think the
careful boys doing for real a nature
adventure and like sleeping out there
anywhere would be sick I've never do the
Wilderness survival merit badge yes
that's one of my favorite merit badges
so this merit badge that two guys I
don't know this one's my favorite bag my
school we didn't need a badge bro we
live this [__] for one trip dude no
every year we didn't take regular trips
all right go ahead you [__] Boy Scout
I'll give your ass a wedgie and kill you
with my handmade tomahawks
that's so cool because as kids you never
really get a chance to like really test
your skills right like let's say let's
say you try to go in the backyard or
mom's like get the [__] back in what are
you doing back there right so for the
Wilderness survival America best correct
me if I'm wrong but it's I think it's
like two or three days and you gotta
build you you gotta build your own
shelter so you find branches you fill in
the the holes like pine needles and all
stuff so you have to make a place to
live and then uh you you have to
actually sleep in there for a couple of
nights or days and then uh I forgot what
else you have to do but it's like the
closest thing that you can in a safe
environment to still be like in nature
yeah and you're like oh [__] this is
dope like I'm really on my own and
you're like [__] like 14 or 15 years
old and you think in your head that
you're really on your own but really
like the area and coordinates they gave
you is like right next to the parking
lot where they have binoculars and they
can totally see you the whole time so
that's it that's the thing with the Eel
River trip we're in the middle of
nowhere we probably traveled like she's
getting mad no there's no [__] badges
it didn't happen man we just got points
like [__] Hogwarts
I got a new dream now I want to go
careful boy camping okay honestly that
sounds so fun let's do it all boys or
what yeah
dude what a loser dude you have to
divorce before we go how about that
sign the papers
[Music]
oh